binance agrees to pay $4.3 billion and
their CEO has pled guilty to violating
money laundering rules and has stepped
down claiming quote I make mistakes and
I must take responsibility now in
exchange for a king's Ransom and the
king's head the doj is expected to
settle their criminal investigation with
binance some think this is the end for
the world's largest crypto exchange
others believe it's a glorified speeding
ticket that's a net win for crypto but
what should you believe it depends on
how much you trust binance let me
explain first context for the past year
there's been criminal and civil
investigations into binance with the SEC
doj and cftc all investigating
accusations of binance accepting us
investors while not being regulated and
then trying to hide that fact why would
they do that well according to their CEO
Chang Pang Zhao who I'll be calling CZ
quote if we blocked us users from day
one binance will not be as big as we are
today it's better to ask for forgiveness
than permission so uh money is the
answer to why they did something illegal
it's always the answer right this is
because as CZ claims 20 to 30% of
binance's potential Revenue was from the
US market so no wonder they kept us
investors but after years of No Control
CZ eventually acknowledge the risk of
allowing us customers he says quote we
do need to block by IP and also know
your customer now this might seem like a
step in the right direction except for a
critical decision CZ maintained a subset
of valuable us users on binance
basically they kicked off the broke
people to look good but conspired to
keep their high value clients quote
contacting us VIP users offline through
direct phone calls leaving no trace the
VIP team would allegedly register a new
separate account for an offshore entity
while the user transferred their
Holdings to the new account so it would
look like that person was no longer from
the US according to CZ himself the
company had to be very careful to skirt
the line using careful language quote we
cannot say they are us users and we want
to help them we say we miscategorized
them as us users but actually they are
not so that's bad but it actually gets
worse see the new filing from the doj
shows these problems extended beyond the
US to binance outright allowing money
launderers to move money through their
Platform One compliance employee even
wrote quote we need a banner is washing
drug money too hard these days come to
binance we got C for you uh what an
example of this was when Hydra a popular
Russian Dark Net Marketplace transferred
$106 million in Bitcoin to binance.com
and laundered their money through it but
not only did binance have little to no
money laundering controls in place even
when illegal funds were found binance
would make special exceptions for their
VIPs in one example example a user was
told to be careful with his flow of
funds especially from darket like Hydra
he can come back with a new account but
this current one has to go it's tainted
but what is the point of flagging money
laundering if you're just going to tell
the guy to start a new account and try
harder next time to not get caught and I
bring these issues up not just because
they're pertinent to the settlement
which they are but also because these
issues demonstrate a problem binance
might have moving forward setting a side
for a moment this $4.3 billion fine part
of this agreement is the expectation
binance is going to stop these illegal
activities you know clean up their act
have an independence compliance monitor
for 3 years but you have to ask yourself
was binance so large and attractive to
crypto people in spite of its loose
money laundering controls offshore
unregulated status or was it because of
it what percentage of binance's Revenue
vanishes overnight with increased
scrutiny
I don't know the answer but it certainly
isn't zero and speaking of challenges
binance faces now let's put the $4.3
billion find back on the table which
itself is a problem can binance afford
to pay it without dipping into customers
funds and becoming insolvent well once
again it depends on how much you believe
binance see binance regularly publishes
a proof of reserves which shows they
have customer assets backed one to one
and billions of dollars on top of it
according to those yeah it's a drop in
the bucket
but proof of reserves don't fully show
liabilities causing people to call for a
full audit for years now but each time
it's met with a less than satisfactory
response from their CEO thus far uh you
haven't disclosed your liabilities and I
wonder why that is and whether you
will yeah so we are working with firms
to do the U audit of financials like
liabilities ETA but audits don't reveal
every problem so
but would reveal that CZ if you could
get a big four auditor to say that if if
you're saying that some of them don't
want to work with you that raises
questions too they don't want to work
with you because you don't have the
files and the data that would make them
feel comfortable signing off and and
giving that stamp of
approval uh actually many of them don't
even know how to audit crypto exchanges
um they don't they don't they don't
really when they so when they audit
they're very used to auditing or firm
does coin coin has reses coin has a big
four
auditor um actually I'm I don't look at
coinbase we don't really look at so
though now hold on wait a second or
you're saying you can't get an audit but
then refuse to acknowledge that your
competitors are working with Auditors
that's a red flag and it's pretty clear
look we just don't know the full story
and I don't bring this up like as a
boogeyman to scare you for no reason
telling you there's a monster under your
bed maybe you know it's something you
legitimately need to think about about
if you have money on binance how much do
you trust binance is telling the truth
and trust them with your money it's
ultimately up to you for me I've always
told you guys keep your money off these
exchanges because what you don't know
can hurt you just listen to binance's
CEO answer questions about his company's
ability to pay steep fines earlier this
year and ask yourself does he sound
confident would you be able to handle it
if somebody asked you for 2.1 billion
dollar back would that be okay would you
be able to still withstand things we're
financially okay including you have $2.1
billion to give away if somebody T to
recw to claw that back you'd still be
fine we'll let the lawyers handle it our
we are financially strong honestly the
right answer is yes we're financially
strong is just not good enough it's
literally one of those answers that
means nothing and by the way the real
fine is double that so especially in
light of that large layoff at the
company earlier this year I'm personally
not optimistic about binance's future
although as I said without a more
detailed look at their finances maybe
from an auditor we can't know for sure
but whether or not you're personally
optimistic or pessimistic I think
there's one thing we can all come
together and learn from on this story
questions concern skepticism of a
company it's not fud it's basic due
diligence and the crypto industry has a
troubling trend of pretending otherwise
earlier this year CZ started dismissing
fud fake news attacks with the number
four like he would just post pictures of
himself Whenever there were problems at
binance and just do do this as if it
magically warded off problems so to see
that same guy less than 12 months later
pleading guilty to charges it has a
level of embarrassment that I've almost
never seen before I say almost because
technically I saw this piece of media on
the most humble billionaire the day
before that from from the same guy who
also made the Sam bankman freed puff
piece and it's definitely worse than
than this uh so as we put Cy On The Wall
of Shame joining many other crypto
people I want to leave you with this
wonderful piece of cringe and as always
thanks for
[Music]
watching hey this is the richest guy in
the world from crypto and you don't even
know him hi my name is CZ he made over
$60 billion but his mom still called him
stupid let me tell you his incredible
story